questi ragazzi questo non lo sono da dj
ed oggi siamo ad un non so contare al
secondo speciale due milioni e mezzo di
iscritti alla ragazzi mi sono accorto
che in quest'anno qui ho fatto un sacco
di klever moto un sacco di video di
cleverbot che sono piaciute un sacco
quindi ho detto ma questo facciamo uno
speciale dedicato proprio al cleverbot e
quindi ai ragazzi domani ci sarà la
speciale quando cazzo molto poco più di
lui
oggi ho voluto fare quando ti cleverbot
quindi niente ragazzi spero che vi
piaccia e io e lui vi auguriamo buona
visione
bella vita io mi chiamo pietro tu ti
chiami cosa nascosta ziato tu non ti
chiami piedi non mi fare l'occhiolino in
questi casi
e chi sarebbe la donna della tua vita ei
sei tu la donna della mia vita
friends on
deciditi puoi parlare italiano inglese
che hanno ma non sei neanche depilata
hai visto hunger games
la ragazza hai visto anche che mi ha
preso hunger games non mi prende fa vj
ma prende under the sea perfetto e ti è
piaciuto qual è qual è il tuo
personaggio preferito
questa è semplice non è il mio è tecnica
bull ma che cosa cazzo c'entra bull ma
hai visto hunger games bici andrea sta
premiando sta prendendo un tè come
adesso te lo saluto
bella a tutti i ragazzi di saper
continuare bella tutti i ragazzi poiché
se non me ne va giuro che mi sta andando
zio giuro i benvenuti in questo nuovo
video
ok è vero io io non sono un robot
chirurgo berranno io non sono un robot
lurido babbano bella a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video non sono un
robot lurido babbano si potrebbe anche
andare se un ragazzo sei una ragazza
spiegati sono un ragazzo o una fame
ventilare innanzitutto io ho 19 anni e
così una lurida cala chiunque a casa il
coraggio di rispondere anche io mi metto
tranquilla stesso la piazza dice non è
questa l'unica gioia e non ha anche
detto l'aggiunto lui perché lo sun java
ed è anche cazzo di risparmi adesso
nulla
ok barbone cazzo stai dando del barbone
assicurati siamo iper scoraggiati in
faccia we wish i ragazzi sta diventando
una roba erotici ma mi sto bagnando
che cazzo mista asciuga tutto qui ge
templio che cosa cazzo ha scritto
traduttore ditemi voi se devo andare sul
produttore per tradurre ste stronzate
amo più la maglia a benedetti e ti sei
lasciato andare la finta ragazzi e
l'acqua che era il bagnato quando uno si
bagna che cosa non metterò mai questo
video su youtube si sono maschio forza
no non sono bagna stavo scherzando sono
bello asciutto anzi sono un font coesa
tuo padre si forma una canna
andiamo a dialogare con la scimmia ora
ragazzi io non so che lingua parli credo
sia solo in inglese adesso vediamo
perché le scimmie hanno questa voce sul
serio fai scimmia my name is matteo
renzi how are you
ecco che anche tanti thank you thank
shisha devo dirgli che sono capace di
parlare con lui quindi i'm able to speak
to speak english speaking senti ma l'hai
visto hunger games
qual è il tuo personaggio preferito il
mio è vita
il tuo se mi risponde bull ma la marzo
giuro riguardo c'è anche edward in
hunger games
dimmi qualcosa di hoc ma ti droghi sono
tutto bagnato no che si va a finire in
cose che ascolta ziona ovvio quanto ti
amo non lo sapevo lingua
vediamo dove arriviamo plastino cari mi
lasci fare vediamo fin dove mi lascia
fare sculaccia la propriet ht dopo miss
che ricorda tocco l'occhiolino pur vai
sculaccia mi fammi sentire vivo che
cazzo sponda quelli cassapanche belle
belle sì sculaccia mi con le cassapanche
belle belle sì se tu mi piaci
vieni a casa e ti faccio sul colpo
mia sorella siamo seri si riesce a
capire qualcosa di quello che sto
dicendo sì si sta arrivando
arriva arriva di che razza è il tuo cane
ma non è un cane non so cosa sei
abituato tromba ti senti ma gli scopi i
cani
fammi capire che il caso
[Musica]
ok ti piace
io non posso scrivere ste cose legate
non posso guardare mentre scrivo perché
i miei mi vergogno no no misto
rifiutando di girare non voglio g è una
roba
no no no no no conosci franklin compreso
e di cazzo è no non lo conosco guardo su
facebook morendo ieri mi ha dato un
milione euro appena un calo di capitoli
da solo se facciamo pace porte ora non
sa io non ho massimo amici noi e noi
siamo molto amici cioè noi amici
giochiamo diglielo 8 francesco di a
termini è una cosa che facciamo però un
milione porca [ __ ] non cambia solo
bionda con gli occhi azzurri sono
abbastanza alta come grazia che anni
[Musica]
secondo mestamente ti piacciono gli fa
vj e la terna torre che lavora con rocco
siffredi che credere come vampiri devo
andare via a [ __ ] c'è basta perché
perché devo mangiare devo andare a
mangiare andare a mangiare mi vuoi
mollare oppure devo staccare tutto così
dove mangiare testa di capi dove vieni
chi bacia vedi che la seduzione la
tattica ti bacio anch'io con tre metri
di lingua andiamo in camere da letto
ok siamo passati ragazzi sta diventando
una roba a trova scienza pietro kiss
filipe mutandine prima tu perché io c'ho
le mutandine sia muri e dopo cosa fai
presto solo mi mandi via così restino da
sola io sono con mio fratello
chi fa il tuo fratello ragazzi è una
cosa io non ho un fratello che problema
al cervello haifa le è il tuo
personaggio preferito di hunger games
la ragazza dico che non ha i numeri non
o no no no no perché c'è il microfono
mentre dice che quello qual è il tuo
personaggio preferito di diritti di un
coming ragazzi qualcuno chiami
un'ambulanza vi prego perché grave la
situazione è finita e peeta te lo sto
dicendo inghirami seminari poterlo so
chi è il tuo personaggio preferito di un
belga nick vita
chi si fa in una voce che mi farà pare
come pochi piacere frate io sono fa vj e
tu chi sei come si trattano i maschi
steve a cazzo piaceri sua manca ma
quindi li metteresti con me che sono
bello perché dovrei non ti conosco
nemmeno sì ma tu sei una scimmia in
teoria non dovresti ricevere tante di
queste richieste anche una campagna con
te il migliore allenatore del mondo cosa
agghiacciante quello che dicono possono
farli j e tu chi sei
mi stata nel maschile steve a cazzo che
ci ri samantha calmi tutti fermi scusa
ma se 6 samantha dopo l'operazione siri
farmi un panino con la nutella subito
non mi è permesso di avvicinarmi ai
fornelli bozza ma io da coupé ma mangia
le forbici e una sotto forma di sadismo
10 ti sento di più la migliore v con una
sua in su
ti rimangono poche ore su questo mondo
oddio scionti ragazzi servito è piaciuto
lasciate commento è un mi piace anche
alla pagina ti sei dimenticata del
ragazzo ho capito aspetta un attimo
cazzo pagina di facebook con i video
trovate una descrizione non siete ancora
iscritti
se non siete ancora iscritti gli scritti
perfetto e noi ci rivediamo nel prossimo
vinto sei ragazzi ecco così si fa e che
cazzo